Hey and hey do you think we get some um
yeah I mean I was just like I was just
like filming here but if you don't
really film there - hi I'm Greg hi I'm
in and woods have enough energy
now the Anne Woods is on social media go
to her [ __ ] now go to description box
and look at her on social media stuff
and platforms and tell her the real
rejects sent you I'm on her profile all
the time all the time just you know I
gotta capture the memories is I don't
make eye contact with her in person no
we can't we're not allowed we're not
allowed it's against the rules
so guys big red l14 was the first one to
request this a while ago he says to me
yo Greg have you seen the trailer for
rupture might if not a highly advise you
watch it but be warned you might cringe
little bit just like I don't even know
what accent I was doing I don't know I
don't either but I enjoyed it it's
usually what woman tell me I don't know
what you were doing but that was
enjoyable accent yeah just the accent
just like I do accents at that most
appropriate times
alright
[Music]
to be tracked
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
because something very special there
this might feel a little bit cold what
he can throw back the genetic code we're
trying to rupture that part of insurance
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what are they doing in this trailer so
they can like control their DNA if
they're part of one of these like
genetic people yeah I don't understand
what the point is for what they're
trying to do though I was definitely
creeped out if that was their point
success success
I mean hey hey greats like this obvious
vision positives visuals we're making
eye contact what are we doing obvious
positives the visuals are great the way
it's shot it kind of reminds me of like
recent horror thrillers like split and
get out has a rather contained
environment vibe focusing on a singular
character who's trying to escape from a
very specific situation in Umi repose is
great at being thrown into horrible
situations you know girl with Dragon
Tattoo from me theists she's very good
at UH at the being a suffering woman
shrink that are we to get the hell out
of the situation but that was an
escalating Lee eerie building trailer
just even when she gets kidnapped it was
like disturbing to watch all the tape go
around her and every yeah weird
interesting it was like electrical tape
yeah really see people use when they
grab that's true when I grab people I
don't use electrical tape yeah usually
duct tape duct tape is the best way to
go and you can find a really good brand
at Home Depot people in the trailer like
this like it showed just enough to where
you know kind of what the story is but
yeah so much that you knew everything by
the end you weren't like oh cool I don't
need to see the movie now yeah left just
enough to where you like well clearly
something's wrong and she has something
very special about her that people want
to take or take her true odds are true
but I still don't like I still don't
know
what the thing is there sorry some next
stage of some of their human evolution
by [ __ ] with her DNA right and like
giving and giving her chemicals and then
fear inducing experiences hmm you know
this could work this could work I think
I believe in such experiments do you do
you want to be subjected to them not
myself oh oh but you would help with
doing that like let's say you like it
right right can I do with some duct tape
yeah I would gladly do this Wow Wow good
to know
mm-hmm okay see you later don't go yet
Michael Chiklis is in this hm-hmm
famously known for playing the thing and
fantastic for his most famous role to
date well you know he's in the shield
and he's also in the fourth season of
American Horror Story so this guy knows
a thing or two about horror usually we
see the chicle you think of the shield
but or the thing but he has experience
in horror I thought he was really good
in American Horror Story than one season
he was in yeah he's good at the
creepiness from the producer of American
sniper totally feels like American
sniper wow I didn't know that yeah and I
love the coloring too I feel like I've
said that before when we watch something
before but I love the the coloring is
really good like the lighting
oh yeah the visual aesthetics are
actually really nice to look at before
evening to my here why was there a
fighter and then there was like one
where she had like spiders my side of
her that yeah yeah might have been in
her imagination I think she'll break out
by the end yeah I mean I hope so
I hope so just because I'm a hopeful
person I hate to see this woman suffer
and then just hope she gets to win in
the end at some point
she's a single bomb you know it's got a
wrap up or a wrap around her kid in some
way exactly
because she even mentions I'm she's like
I need my son or like where's my son or
something so like this he has something
to do with it
maybe the son comes in and saves the day
maybe the little boy comes in with a gun
and shoots them all up yeah I'm good at
predicting movies and I think that's
gonna happen well that was a cool
trailer
hey big red oh one for you dog you
yeah ruptured my spleen tensley if
you're new to the channel you know what
you can choose to do and this is your
choice no one's telling you to do this
but it would be nice and I would
appreciate it especially in these times
on YouTube you can subscribe for the
real rejects and one man woods on
Instagram lovely pics
she has a youtube videos so she will hey
but you should subscribe now anyway and
watch whatever is currently up there
lord knows I do and you can follow Jesus
Christ on Jesus Christ comm it's it's
it's really lovely they got all kinds of
speakers on there Joel Osteen Moses Mel
Brooks it gives them yeah Gibson Brooks
is not a Jesus Christ
[Laughter]